(guitar music)
- I'm Audrey.
- I'm Johnathan.
- And we're siblings.
- We're brothers.
- This is my mommy.
- We're cousins.
- Justin is my younger brother.
- Yes.
- We're gonna be
- drinking
- moonshine
- in slow motion
- for the first time ever.
- Looks like it hasn't been made in a bathtub.
- I hope it doesn't taste like gasoline.
^- I don't really drink ever.
- Ugh!
- On an empty stomach too.
- I know, exactly.
- Cheers.
- Go down, up, down.
- Alright, down, up, down.
- You gotta make yourself
look cool.
- Oh yeah.
- Ready?
- Cheer, no at the same time.
(laughs)
(adventurous music)
- That was not as bad as I expected.
(gags)
- Tastes like a frat party.
- Didn't even take it!
- I did!
- No you didn't!
- Yes I did.
- You drank like this much.
Look what you did!
- Oh you drank that
whole thing, are you kidding?
- Yes!
- I can't drink this whole thing
in one shot.
- Yes you can!
- Yeah.
- It went down pretty smoothly.
- Just very hot.
- It is.
- I'm getting bathroom cleaner.
- Wanna help me? (laughs)
- What are you, no no no, oh.
- It freaks me out a little bit.
- I mean I just think of an old, skinny man in a mountain.
- I'm not a fan, I wouldn't reach for it
after a long day at work
- Actually I would.
Now that it's settled in, I feel warm and fuzzy.
(laughs)
(coughs)
- We should eat something now.
(bubbly music)